obviously women find him very attractive
fast forward a year and Emily
radakowski's apparently been Charmed by
Pete just months after his split from
Kim Kardashian you just gotta roll with
it a source confirms to E.T the comedian
and model are seeing each other quote
Pete and Emily have known each other for
a while because they run in similar
circles they've always had a good time
together and liked each other and it
turns out Pete and Emily have a history
the two worked on a photo shoot together
which Pete says he totally bombed so
they're like crushing it right yeah
really like you get what you paid for
and feel bad cause I'm holding up like
Emily and like everyone you know
everybody has to do so
um all of a sudden Dave stops the thing
and he goes Pete he goes you're a fish
he goes you're a fish be a fish for me
Pete you're a fish be a fish
and he was like can you do that for me
can you be a fish I was like I I guess I
could be a little busy boy and when
Emily talked to Seth Meyers herself she
defended Pete he's a professional yeah
first of all you should know that about
Pete and he got um into character in a
real way and was kind of doing like a
um that worked really well yeah oh and
she also weighed in on why she thinks
women find Pete so attractive following
his romances with Kate Beckinsale Ariana
Grande Kya Gerber and more Hollywood
Beauties he's got the height he is
obviously women find him very attractive
yeah well obviously yeah you're right I
don't know why I'm like how's that guy a
model yeah yeah I feel like only other
men feel that way you guys are like wow
what's that guy got and I'm like I mean
he seems super Charming he's vulnerable
he's lovely his fingernail polish is
awesome like he looks good good
relationship with his mother yeah great
relationship with his mother we love it
and now our sources say Pete and Emily
have been spending one-on-one time with
each other and the vibe our source calls
it flirtatious adding Emily's playing
the field and enjoying dating both Emily
and Pete are fresh off breakups the
model filed for divorce from Sebastian
bear McLeod in sept September and she's
since been romantically linked to Brad
Pitt
really strong entertaining entertaining
story however in October Emily made her
relationship status very clear quote I'm
newly single for basically the first
time in my life ever and I just feel
like I'm kind of enjoying the freedom of
not being super worried about how I'm
being perceived I think that you know
just in general now being someone who's
in the public eye and has experienced
that so much I really encourage people
to have a healthy
um
a little bit of disbelief of and and
wanting you know and just understand
that these these headlines are designed
for people to click
eventually and for Pete fans are just
getting a glimpse of his field romance
with Kim on her reality show Pete is has
got to be literally the best human being
I've ever met like the best heart people
always say like oh he's so funny and
it's like has to do with how funny he is
that's like fourth on my list of why I
like him he's just super genuine yeah
and it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch TV and just do nothing the two
called it quits after nine months
together totally fine as for where the
former couples stand today last month A
source told ET that the two have
remained friendly since their split
quote Pete and Kim still keep in touch
it wasn't a bad Fallout or breakup so
things are good between them and they've
remained in contact
[Music]
thank you